vincent peillon commençons non pas par
les questions qui fâchent mais par les
interrogations est ce que le fait de
souffrir de vendre l'an 2 signifie clan
un cédez pas terrible non je vous
propose du tout il y avait une demande 1
et envoie la pression maintenant dans un
temps politique qui devrait toujours
être court mais lent a été un une année
très plein avec un nombre d'actions
incroyable peut-être même trop parce que
je constate très souvent que nos
concitoyens et même les commentateurs ne
connaissent pas ou le détail de ce qui a
été fait tant sur le plan économique que
sur d'autres plans je pense par exemple
à l'école dont des fondations été posée
dans un moment où chacun le disent a été
rappelé hier qui est quand même très
difficile avec un panache et la richesse
sociale c'est pour ça que la droite
devant la baisse des charges immédiate
et considère que tout ça c'est une perte
de temps qu'on attend le retournement de
la situation du chômage mais que dans ce
cadre de récession il faudrait d'abord
et avant tout baisser les charges et
vite
en fait si vous voulez c'est toute la
difficulté française est ce que nous
voulons maintenant que la politique donc
l'action publique redevienne quelque
chose de sérieux
vous me dites il faut baisser les
charges et la droite dit que j'ai bien
compris que si bien compris la droite
dit que juste acquis obtenus en mai nous
venons de le faire c'est le crédit impôt
compétitivité ça ne s'est jamais fait
n'importe quel commentateurs sérieux et
la droite devrait le reconnaître
puisqu'elle ne demande elle-même elle
n'a pas eu le courage de le faire
ces 20 milliards vous imaginez
d'ailleurs puisque je voyais qu'il
guillaume tabard évoqué à la question de
la social démocratie
la gauche arrive aux responsabilités et
c'était quand même pas sa politique
traditionnelle
elle fait ce crédit impôt betty tivité
suite au rapport gallois donc on parlait
des grandes réformes de l'année ça ce
sont des très grandes réformes de
structures comme la banque publique
d'investissement comme les réformes que
je peux conduire sur le plan scolaire
comme la réforme du marché du travail ce
sont des réformes de structure et il
faut accepter l'idée de bord j'accepte
tout à fait l'idée qu'ils ne soyons pas
nécessairement parfait
mais accepter l'idée que des réformes et
les effets des réformes ça prend un
certain temps parce qu'à force d'avoir
voulu toujours agir dans l'instant on a
perdu 10 ans avaient péri